[Music]
tired of the frustrations of politics
and policy school reformers to take into
turning to the court to drive real
reform most famous example of this is
the Vergara lawsuit in California in
which the judge ruled at California's
tenure laws violated the right of
students to get an effective education a
lot to sympathise with in that ruling
even if it was later overturned by the
state Supreme Court a couple problems
though with learning to the court first
the reality is that the judge can say
you can't have teacher tenure it's not
clear what else such as can throw out
can they say no charter schools no
school vouchers it's a real risk second
courts are no panacea the state of New
Jersey has been in a long-running
lawsuit for a half-century which the
Abbott school districts have gotten
billions in extra aid and still aren't
serving kids well I'm a big fan of
changing schools a way that serves kids
but I think the most promising routes
lives through the hard work of politics
and policy and not the freezing
shortcuts offered by the court to learn
more about my fake old school reform
check the links in the description below
also let us know what other topics you'd
like a EEI scholars to cover in 60
seconds